für edith test also ich kann schon mal
kein idiot sein denn ich habe rudi aus
der simply clever das squaire to begin
damit jetzt bin ich raus spaß beiseite
wir klicken natürlich auf den square und
jetzt sollen wir auf den großen roten
button trinken natürlich drauf jetzt
müssen wir auf das
hätte ich mein englisch besser
aufgepasst rectangle heißt rechteck also
klicken wir natürlich hier drauf red
button and waste and the green but nova
13 man könnte meinen da ist tatsächlich
was drin
reste blueberry times länder orange
button vor times ok 123
[Musik]
123 123 hier so
o
ein idiot also eine katze press die
apéro ans ende dollar 2012
[Applaus]
jetzt sollen wir wieder das rechteck
zweimal anklicken das ist das hier und
hier ist es das
[Musik]
a hast du dich nämlich fast gekriegt
ich bin mir
für mich hier
wir sollen jetzt das ixs drücken und
dann kommen wir weiter pressen die
yellow button once and blue button ende
jänner hatte das ist schon zu viel
12 ha
a
so sind der durchschnitt
das beschreibt ihr leben eigentlich ganz
gut wir sollen jetzt den kleinsten roten
knopf drücken die sache ist wir haben
hier oben ein ich glaube allerdings gibt
noch einen kleineren hier vielleicht
der punkt lösung hat geklappt
light blue square okay
square zum quadrat
wie nennt man es wenn man hilfe von
einem geländefahrzeug bekommt quadrat
im quadrat wir sollen das hellste
quadrat anwählen von erst das hier
selbstverständlich posten des clans
press green button wir gelernt wir
machen jetzt absolut gar nix das kann
nicht gut
wir sind keine smart ja ich mache den
test hier jetzt schon ziemlich lange ich
bin multi intelligent rest wird green
button to continue ok grüner knopf
present the numbers vor ort konnten jo
ok hier vielleicht immer einen schritt
voraus sein aber jetzt auf die vier
kinder over to continue ok labs accounts
blut schweiß und christlicher denke ich
hier ist der rote kreis dann das blaue
dreieck und das grüne rechtecke
gleisdreieck muss nicht sein
ich bin kleinwagen to continue presto
green circle ok grüner kreis ich jetzt
alles von vorne machen musste ich diese
website
[Musik]
ich wollte schon cool mut machen von
links ich bin schlau ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass das so knackt wäre nicht
das komplette spiel jetzt noch mal bis
zu der stelle wo wir versagt haben
durchspielen muss möchte ich euch ganz
kurz darauf aufmerksam machen dass heute
nacht um 0 uhr eine neue podcast folge
online geht es unter anderem um folgende
situation geht alles andere wäre es
ihnen maske das ist ein amerikanischer
schauspieler
der war bei ziemlich beste freunde und
jetzt hat eine serie heraus gebracht die
ich heute anfangen gucke wo angucken
wollte bei netflix
der neue reichste mensch der welt
tatsächlich nicht mehr doch dieses wäre
doch dieses sagt was hat er gemacht hat
dann gold geklaut wollte ich auch mal
bank aus raum aber habe ich nie getan
würde man von heute die banken alle zwei
wochen
[Musik]
das party feiert uns lästig und du
wir sind zurück sie sind zurück im game
meine lieben freunde
ich drücke nun den grünen kreis und ganz
schnell gehen und jetzt den preis
nicht so sehr wieder drin presse yellows
puerto contini okay du bist jetzt die
ganze zeit haarscharf mit dabei sein
weil es könnte wieder ein ganz schöner
test kommen also so schnell lesen
blutbad
so viel zählen
ich mache einfach screenshot decker
also blau dreimal zack zack zack grün
dreimal gelb zweimal 12 und roth 4 x 12
43 bin brilliance komplett
komplett ohne medien hieß es brillant
den idiotentest durchgespielt
[Musik]
ich bin schlau ich wollte einfach nur
mitteilen dass es offiziell kein idiot
binder
warum ich habe so einen idiotentest
gemacht habe den durchgespielt
es führte
[Applaus]
sexy aus
sandra ich sehe dich nicht und ich
glaube dass auch besser so
und ich habe noch platz zu haben
wie heißt du denn auf instagram
laserdrucker anderer stelle mich dass
heute wieder ist alex auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ich habe ja vor 12 wochen
hier schon mal einen idiotentest auf
einem kanal hochgeladen
dann ging es allerdings um ein video ist
uns angeguckt haben mit einigen rätseln
da habe ich selbstverständlich auch
alles geschafft also wenn ihr euch das
angucken wollte könnte einfach hier oben
jetzt klicken ich verlinke euch das dort
und heute habe ich nochmal divisionen
test macht ihr vor einigen jahren schon
mal auf menschen gemacht habe wenn es
euch gefallen hat er das kann einen
daumen hoch und abonniert keinen weiter
und wenn ihr noch ein hu die brauche ich
keine ahnung wo es den ägyptern shop.de
[Musik]